WOULD YOU TIME TO WAKE UP.
TUCKER, THANK YOU FOR A GREAT
SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BY THE WAY, THANK YOU TO THE
BRAVES MEN AND WOMEN WITH HONOR
AND DISTINCTION AND YOU GIVE US
MORE FREEDOMS AND LIBERTIES AND
WE CAN NEVER REPAY YOU AND
TONIGHT WE HONOR YOU HAD ALSO
TONIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO BREAK
DOWN ALL OF THE INSANITY, THE
MADNESS THAT IS GOING TO ENFOLD
US WE.
ALL OF THAT HYPOCRISY, YOU'VE
GOT THE DO-NOTHING HYPOCRITICAL
SOCIALIST DEMOCRATS, EVERYTHING
THEY'VE GOT PLANNED FOR THE WEEK
AND FRANKLY BEYOND IN THE NEXT
358 DAYS OR SO UNTIL ELECTION
DAY, I CAN ONLY GET MY VOLUME UP
HERE, SOMEWHERE, IT'S NOT
WORKING.
ANYWAY, WE WILL ALSO BREAK DOWN
WHAT REPUBLICANS NEED TO BE
DOING AND JUST HOW DANGEROUS
INTEREST FOR US IT WOULD BE TO
BE --
TO ELECT TO THIS RADICAL GROUP
OF EXTREMISTS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
THIS IS WITCH HUNTS 2.0.
UKRAINE.
OKAY.
BUT ON HUMAN GROWTH HORMONE AND
STEROIDS.
IT'S A NEW PROCESS AGAIN,
RAMPANT HYPOCRISY AGAIN, WHILE
HIS GREASY THERE IS AGAIN AND
ALL LED BY A CORRUPT AND
COMPROMISE, A COWARD AND
CONGENITAL LIAR.
HIS NAME IS ADAM SCHIFF.
HE HAS BEEN HELL-BENT ON
SMEARING THIS PRESIDENT NOW FOR
THREE LONG YEARS AND NO MATTER
WHAT LIE HE HAS TO TELL, HE WILL
TELL IT.
NO MATTER HOW CORRUPT, NO MATTER
WHAT LACKING OF DUE PROCESS,
HE'S GOING TO LET IT ALL HAPPEN.
LET NOT YOUR HEARTS BE TROUBLED,
HE HAS LIED TO THIS COUNTRY FOR
THREE STRAIGHT YEARS.
WE KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING TO
PLAY OUT IN THE END AND THAT IS
IN THREE TO 58 DAYS, THAT YOU,
WE COME OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
WE ULTIMATELY GET TO DECIDE HOW
THIS ENDS AND FORMER DEMOCRATIC
MAYOR OF SAN FRANCISCO, HE
ACTUALLY SUMS IT UP PRETTY
NICELY, WILLIE BROWN, WRITING,
"DEMOCRATS WHO SPENT THE NEXT
FEW PARCELS WERE ACTING OUT OF
HER JOHN'S CLIFFHANGER INTO
WHICH EVERYONE KNOWS THE SCRIPT
AND THE ENDING AND COME NEXT
YEAR, TRUMP WILL HAVE AN
IMPEACHMENT VICTORY QUITE
POSSIBLY, LIKELY, I WOULD SAY,
SOLID ECONOMY, THE DEMOCRATS
WILL HAVE WHAT?
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING."
WOULD LOOK AT WHAT
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID.
IMPEACHMENT IN THE SENATE WILL
BE DEAD ON ARRIVAL.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO BRING THIS
CASE FORWARD.
WITHOUT US KNOWING THAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS AND HAVING A
CHANCE TO CROSS-EXAMINE THEM
WITHOUT ANY VICES THEY MAY HAVE.
IF THEY DON'T CALL THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IN THE HOUSE,
THIS THING IS DEAD ON ARRIVAL IN
THE SENATE.
>> Sean: THE KIN GROUP
CORRUPT, CONGENITAL LIAR, SCHIFF
SHOW TRIAL, THIS IS ONE BIG HUGE
SCAM, HYPOCRISY ON A LEVEL THAT
IS BREATHTAKING.
HERE IS WHY.
THERE IS NO DUE PROCESS.
THEY TRIED TO --
THERE'S NO DUE PROCESS
WHATSOEVER BECAUSE EVERY SINGLE
PIECE OF EVIDENCE, EVERY RULE,
EVERY WITNESS, CALLED IN THIS
WHOLE PROCEDURE, EVERY QUESTION
ASKED, IS THE DESCRIPTION OF
THAT GUY, THAT BIG LIAR, THE
CONGENITAL LIAR, WHICH IS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT
NEWT GINGRICH GAVE BILL CLINTON
IN 1998.
ADAM SCHIFF, THE CONGENITAL
LIAR, AND HE ALONE, WILL HAVE
THE POWER TO DENY ANY REQUEST
FROM THE PRESIDENT AND ATTORNEYS
AND WRECKING MEMBERS OF THE
REPUBLICANS WERE ON THE
COMMITTEE, THEY HAVE NO REAL
POWER, THEY HAVE NO REAL SAY.
THIS IS REALLY A CORRUPT CIRCUS.
THIS IS BEYOND A SHOW TRIAL,
BEYOND THE KANGAROO COURT.
G6 CAN DENY ANY WITNESS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
HE CAN PREVENT ANY PIECE OF
EVIDENCE FROM BEING PRESENTED
READ REMEMBER HOW HE LIED ABOUT
HAVING ALL OF THE EVIDENCE, ALL
OF THIS TIME ABOUT TRUMP, RUSSIA
COLLUSION?
HE LIED ABOUT ROBERT MUELLER'S
FINDINGS, HE LIED ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL WITH
UKRAINE, EVEN FABRICATING THE
ENTIRE TRANSCRIPT, AND THEN HE
LIED ABOUT HIS INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE HEARSAY COME IN
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
AND DESPITE SCHIFF DENYING
HAVING ANY CONTACT WITH THIS
INDIVIDUAL, WELL, WE LEARNED
THAT IN FACT, HIS OFFICE HAD
BEEN CLOSELY ADVISING THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER BEFORE EVEN
FILING THE COMPLAINT WHICH
BRINGS US TO OUR SECOND POINT
AND THAT IS THAT MAN RUNNING THE
SHOW TRIAL STARTING TOMORROW
PUBLICLY IS TOTALLY COMPROMISED.
HE IS A MATERIAL WITNESS IN THIS
CHARADE.
CASEY IS NOW APPOINTED HIMSELF
JUDGE JURY AND EXECUTIONER
VETTED SCHIFF, RADICAL EXTREME
SOCIALIST BASE, AND THE MOB THE
MEDIA, NONE OF THEM ARE
IMPARTIAL ACTORS THAT REALLY
CARE ABOUT TRUTH AND JUSTICE.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
THIS IS AND HAS BEEN FOR THE
GET-GO, A POLITICAL HIT JOB AND
WE KNOW THIS BECAUSE THEY HAD
BEEN PLANNING THIS BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT WAS EVEN SWORN IN.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> IF HE TAKES THE RISK OF GOING
TO TRY, HE IS CONVICTED, THAT
COULD BE SEEN AS AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> MAYBE WITH ONE OF HIS
CHILDREN, THERE WAS AT LEAST A
CHANCE HE WOULD BE IMPEACHED.
>> THERE ARE TOOLS THAT CONGRESS
HAS.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW THAT WOULDN'T
BE IMPEACHABLE.
>> IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHABLE.
>> IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> ALL THAT MAY BE IMPEACHABLE.
>> IMPEACHMENT.
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO GO IN THERE
AND WE ARE GOING TO --
>> IMPEACHABLE.
>> IF THAT'S ON IMPEACHABLE, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT HIS PRINTS
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT BE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE.
>> IMPEACHABLE.
>> 100% IS IMPEACHABLE.
>> GUILTY OF HIGH CRIME AND
MISDEMEANORS.
>> GROUNDS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
>> TALK OF IMPEACHMENT PAID >>
NONE OF US CAME TO CONGRESS TO
IMPEACH A PRESIDENT BUT NOW WE
HAVE TO DO OUR DUTY.
>> Sean: AFTER THE RUSSIA
HOAX, CONSPIRACY THEORY LIES
REAL IN THEIR FACE, FOUR
SEPARATE INVESTIGATIONS COME AT
THE EYE, NOTHING, HOUSE INTEL,
NOTHING, BIPARTISAN SENATE
COMMITTEE, NOTHING, MUELLER,
NOTHING, ALL RIGHT, WE WON'T
WASTE THREE MORE YEARS, WE GO TO
A BACKUP PLAN INVOLVING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HAYDEN'S
PHONE CALL WITH UKRAINE.
THERE WERE EIGHT EXAMPLES OF
QUID PRO QUO'S.
THAT'S A LIE TOO AND YOU KNOW
WHAT, IT JUST SHOWS WHERE THEIR
MIND IS SET AND WHERE IT'S AT AT
THIS TIME.
WHILE THE PUBLIC INVOLVED IN
THIS, WE GOT THE TRANSCRIPT OF
THE PRESIDENT'S CALL.
NO QUID PRO QUO, NO MISCONDUCT
WHATSOEVER, JUST ON THE OTHER
HAND, THE PRESIDENT DOING HIS
JOB, FAITHFULLY EXECUTING THE
LAWS OF THIS LAND AND THE
CURRENT FRONT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THAT WOULD BE
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE BIDEN, HE IS ON TAPE, JUST
LIKE THE ONLY RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE WAS HILLARY'S
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER, THE
ONLY QUID PRO QUO IS JOE BIDEN
ON TAPE BRAGGING ABOUT SHAKING
DOWN THE VERY SAME COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE WITH A REAL
BILLION-DOLLAR TAX MONEY, WE SAW
IT ON TAPE.
HE'S BRAGGING, THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE, YOU HAVE SIX HOURS TO
FIRE YOUR TOP PROSECUTOR, WELL,
WHAT HE WAS TOLD WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS HERO, ZERO,
NON, EXPERIENCED SON, WHO IS
PAID MILLIONS, FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR AT SIX HOURS, YOU GET
A BILLION.
DON'T FIRE THE PROSECUTOR, YOU
DON'T GET A BILLION.
WELL, SON OF A --
THEY FIRED HIM AND AT THE VERY
SAME TIME, THE VERY SAME
PROSECUTOR, YEAH, WE NOW KNOW HE
WAS INVESTIGATING HIS SON,
HUNTER, ZERO EXPERIENCED HUNTER,
ALONG WITH HUNTER'S COMPANY COME
IN UKRAINIAN AND GAS GIANT,
BURISMA HOLDINGS.
NO EXPERIENCE HUNTER, NO
EXPERIENCE IN OIL, GAS, ENERGY,
OR IN UKRAINE, SO NOW, WHY WOULD
SOMEBODY WITH NO EXPERIENCE BE
PAID MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BY A COMPANY IN UKRAINE
WHEN HIS FATHER IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT IN CHARGE OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION POLICIES IN
UKRAINE?
GREAT QUESTION.
ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW REPORT
FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES," EVEN
BIDEN'S OLD AGE AND CONCERN
ABOUT HUNDREDS UKRAINIAN
BUSINESS DEALINGS, THEY WERE SO
WORRIED ABOUT THE OBJECTS THAT
THEY LISTED STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIALS TO GATHER FACTS TO
DETERMINE HOW TO HANDLE THE
STORY SO LET'S RECAP.
YOU'VE GOT A CONGENITAL,
COMPROMISE, BACK QUICKNESS LIAR,
LEADING THIS CIRCUS SO TRIAL
AGAINST A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENTS OF THE UNITED STATES
THAT HE PERSONALLY HAS BEEN
TRYING TO GET RID OF FOR THREE
YEARS, LYING ABOUT FOR THREE
YEARS, HE'S OFFERING NO NEW
PROCESS, ALL WHILE THE
PRESIDENT'S POLITICAL OPPONENT
IS ON CAMERA BRAGGING ABOUT THE
VERY THING THAT WE ARE ALL
SUPPOSED TO BE UPSET ABOUT AND
THE EXACT SAME COUNTRY FOR WHICH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONGFULLY
ACCUSED.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
READ THE TRANSCRIPT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHTLY
PERFORMING HIS CONSTITUTIONAL
SWORN DUTY.
THAT'S RIGHT.
HE IS SWORN TO UPHOLD THE LAWS
OF THIS LAND.
BY THE WAY, WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT
WITH UKRAINE IN TERMS OF
COOPERATION ON CRIMINAL MATTERS
AND ELECTION INTERFERENCE
BECAUSE UKRAINE, WE KNOW, HAVE
BEEN ABATED BY THE WAY, WHEN DID
WE START GOING ABOUT FOREIGN
COUNTRIES INTERFERING IN OUR
ELECTIONS?
HIS NAME INTERFERENCE DETAILED
BY POLITICO, JANUARY 11, 2017,
DETAILED HOW A REAL DNC
OPERATIVE WORKING WITH THE
UKRAINIAN EMBASSY TRYING TO DIG
UP DIRT TO SMEARED DONALD TRUMP
AND HIS ASSOCIATES, BOLSTERING
THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, ACTUALLY
HAPPENED.
BY THE WAY, THAT WAS A COURT
DECISION ON UKRAINE THAT
ACTUALLY UPHELD THAT COURT STORY
AS WELL.
THE REAL DELUSION, JUST LIKE THE
REAL CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN DOSSIER, THE REALLY
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE, AND I WE
SEE UKRAINE INTERFERENCE TO HELP
HILLARY.
FOR GOOD MEASURE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PLANNING NOW
TO RELEASE THE TRANSCRIPT OF
ANOTHER CALL WITH UKRAINE WHICH
I THINK IS A GREAT IDEA AND
SHOULD BE A NEW STANDARD FOR
THIS TIME TO DEMAND THAT ALL IS
JOE BIDEN'S TRANSCRIPTS, OF ALL
OF HIS PHONE CALLS WITH UKRAINE,
HE MADE PUBLIC.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE AT IT, I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S TRANSCRIPTS
WITH THE COUNTRY OF RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN AFTER HE PROMISED
TO HAVE MORE FLEXIBILITY AFTER
MY ELECTION.
IT WAS ALSO SEE THE TRENDS GOES
PERHAPS FROM OBAMA'S
CONVERSATIONS WITH IRANIAN
LEADERS AND THE LEAD UP TO HIM
GIVING THAT HATE AMERICA IRAN
$150 BILLION OF OUR CASH AND
OTHER CURRENCY.
AFTER ALL, WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THERE IS NO QUID PRO QUO'S.
IT'S RIGHT NOW IT'S TIME FOR
REPUBLICANS TO GET TOUGH.
SENATOR REPUBLICANS NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION.
WE ALL KNOW SCHIFF IS GOING TO
BEAT UP PRETTY MUCH ANY AND ALL
WITNESSES THAT WILL HAMPER HIS
NARRATIVE, HIS HOAX, HIS
WITCH HUNTS, IN THE HOUSE.
REPUBLICANS OF THE POWER IN THE
SENATE, THAT MEANS YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO SUBPOENA PEOPLE.
THERE ARE WITNESSES THAT NEED TO
BE SUBPOENAED IMMEDIATELY AND I
WOULD START WITH THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
WHO IS COMPLAINING TOTALLY ON
HEARSAY.
WE KNOW HE WAS CLOSE TO
JOE BIDEN.
WE KNOW HE'S A DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVIST.
WE KNOW HE HAD CONTACT WITH
SCHIFF'S OFFICE BEFORE HE FILED
A COMPLAINT.
NOW HE NEEDS TO ANSWER SOME
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
WHERE DID YOU GET YOUR
INFORMATION, DID SCHIFF'S OFFICE
HELP WRITE THE COMPLAINT, DID
THEY ADVISE YOU TO GET AN
ATTORNEY, GO TO THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL, WHAT ARE YOUR TIES TO
JOHN BRENNAN?
YOUR FORMER BOSS, WHAT WAS THE
NATURE OF YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH
JOE BIDEN IN THIS CAMPAIGN, DID
YOU COLLUDE WITH ANYBODY IN
SCHIFF'S OFFICE?
BY THE WAY, WE SHOULD ALSO BRING
IN ADAM SCHIFF AND HIS OFFICE.
HE SHOULD HAVE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND BY THE WAY,
MEMBERS OF HIS STAFF, BY THE
WAY, THEY DON'T HAVE PRIVILEGE
PAID STAFF TO SHOW UP.
THEY CAN BE SUBPOENAED AND THEY
CAN ALL BE PUT UNDER OATH IN THE
U.S. SENATE.
THEY NEED TO ANSWER FOR THEIR
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE SONY
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
IT'S ALSO TIME TO PUT HUNTER
BIDEN UNDER OATH.
DID HE SPEAK WITH HIS FATHER
ABOUT HIS UKRAINIAN BUSINESS
DEALS?
THEIR STATEMENTS WE ALREADY KNOW
AND IT POINTED OUT ARE IN
CONFLICT WITH EACH OTHER.
WHEN ON "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
TIPPED OFF JOE BIDEN AND THEN
HIS SON WAS BEING INVESTIGATED
BY THE PROSECUTOR IN UKRAINE.
THAT WOULD MEAN JOE, WELL, HE
COME TOO, SHOULD BE SUBPOENAED,
LIKE ADAM SCHIFF AND HUNTER
BIDEN SHOULD BE SUBPOENAED LIKE
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER SHOULD BE
SUBPOENAED.
BY THE WAY, WHAT IT HUNTER SAY
TO HIS FATHER?
QUESTION WHAT DID
HE ASK FOR FAVORS GROSS MARGIN
HUNTER BIDEN KNOW THAT PARIS
SMOKE WAS PAYING HIM BILLIONS
FOR NO EXPERIENCE AND WAS IN
FACT USING HIS NAME TO GET THE
OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT TO DO
FAVORS FOR SCHIFF HOLDINGS?
THE NEXT PRESIDENT WOULD NEED TO
GO UNDER OATH IS FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT, YES, JOE BIDEN
HIMSELF.
HE SHOULD BE SUBPOENAED.
WHAT DID HE REALLY KNOW AND WHEN
HE DID HE KNOW THAT HIS SON WAS
BEING INVESTIGATED, HOW MANY
PEOPLE WARN HIS SON WAS BEING
INVESTIGATED, WHAT WAS HE AWARE
THAT THE UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
THAT HE GOT FIRED WAS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON AND HOW
MANY TIMES WAS HE TOLD HIS SON
WAS IN FACT INVESTIGATED?
WHAT ROLE DID HIS SON PLAY IN
U.S. POLICY IN UKRAINE, IF ANY?
NEXT, HUNTER'S BUSINESS PARTNER,
DEVIN ARCHER, WHAT DID HE SAY TO
VICE PRESIDENT BUT BIDEN ABOUT
BURISMA?
ALSO NELLIE OHR NEEDS TO BE
FORCED TO TESTIFY UNDER OATH IN
THE U.S. SENATE.
SHE WORKED FOR FUSION GPS.
ALONG WITH CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
HER HUSBAND, FOURTH RANKING
HIGHEST NUMBER OF THE DOJ,
RUSSIAN MISINFORMATION
THROUGHOUT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT, WHAT DID SHE GET
FROM UKRAINE?
ALSO WE NEED TO BRING IN FORMER
DNC CONTRACTOR, OPERATIVE,
ALEXANDER TRULY LOVE.
REMEMBER POLITICO IN
JANUARY 2017 DETAILED HER
EFFORTS TO MEET WITH UKRAINIANS
IN THE UKRAINIAN EMBASSY.
DID SHE COLLUDE ON BEHALF OF THE
DNC AND HURLEY CLINTON?
DID THEY ACTUALLY GET DIRT FROM
UKRAINE?
DID SHE ENLIST THE EFFORTS OF
THIS FOREIGN GOVERNMENT ON
HILLARY CLINTON'S BEHALF WHO
AWARDED HER TO DO IT?
ALSO, INVESTOR VOLKER MUST BE
CALLED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS UNDER
OATH AS WELL.
DID HE HAVE ANY DIRECT EVIDENCE
OF AIDS UKRAINE BEING TIED TO A
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN?
WAS THE EIGHT ACTUALLY
DELIVERED?
DO YOU THINK CORRUPTION IN
UKRAINE IS A LEGITIMATE CONCERN
FOR A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
EVERYTHING THAT YOU WITNESSED
THIS WEEK IS ALL ABOUT THE
UPCOMING ELECTION.
THE SENATE REPUBLICANS HAVE THE
POWER TO BRING IN ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE AND THEY SHOULD ISSUE THE
SUBPOENAS.
THEY'VE GOT TO REJECT HOUSE
DEMOCRATS THAT ARE CORRUPT,
HYPOCRITICAL, ABUSING THEIR
POWER, DIVIDING THE COUNTRY, AND
REALLY THEY NEED TO GET TO THE
TRUTH IN THE SENATE.
THE TRUTH ABOUT THE FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO CLEARLY HAD A
POLITICAL AGENDA, THE TRUTH
ABOUT THE COMPROMISED CORRUPT
ADAM SCHIFF, THE TRUTH ABOUT
QUID PRO QUO JOE, IT'S TIME TO
EXPOSE THIS WITCH HUNT FOR WHAT
IT IS.
WE WILL HAVE MORE OF MY